many are upset that biden's doj seems to
be defending president trump in the eg
carroll case where he is accused of
sexual assault
and this one is more complicated than it
seems this all relates to the westfall
act which basically gives immunity to
employees of the government who
undertake actions
in the course of their employment and
it's not unreasonable to assume that
allegations of sexual assault don't
relate to the course and scope of your
employment as a federal employee
but it's more complicated than that the
aging carol case relates to former
president trump's
statements while in office she's
accusing him of defamation by denying
the allegations
and defenders of this move point out
that politicians have to talk about
their personal lives in office
all the time number two that if these
kinds of statements were not immune
you'd get all kinds of crazy suits any
time any politician
said anything and number three there is
prior case law where a politician has
received westfall immunity
when talking about their personal lives
in office but bottom line this is a
complicated issue and there are no easy
answers